if you've been thinking about getting a
portable SSD for your computer this
video is for you we're gonna compare
four of the top portable SSDs to see
which one is the better Buy in terms of
various categories like design size
portability performance and more and
we're not only going to run the standard
performance benchmarks but we're also
gonna transfer massive files over to
these drives to heat them up and see
which drive performs the best under
stress and let me tell you there
definitely were a few surprises you
don't want to miss these aren't any
regular SSDs they're the fastest ones
out there and that's because they all
use Thunderbolt 3 which allows for
transfer speeds that are over five times
as fast as regular USB C SSDs and since
every single new Mac in most new Windows
laptops and many desktop computers are
starting to come with Thunderbolt 3
ports these SSDs are the future so let's
compare everything about these for
portable SSDs to see which one you
should buy in 2020 first off we've got
Samsung's super clean almost Tesla like
x5 SSD then we've got the tried-and-true
LaCie rugged SSD pro we've also got the
G technology G Drive mobile pro by
Western Digital which is also very
reliable and finally the envoi Pro X or
X from the well known Mac centric brand
o WC now before we get into this
comparison I want to mention that each
of these drives has one terabyte of
storage which I would say is the best
choice for the price let's start off our
comparison with portability the o WC is
by far the bulkiest drive out of the
bunch followed by the G Drive and then
the Samsung x5 with the LaCie drive
being the most portable by far in terms
of design I think the x5 takes the cake
with the really unique shape painted
finish in accents on the side and bottom
it's the only one that really screams
premium the LaCie is the runner up with
a really simple and clean black design
and while I don't really like the extra
blue accents on the G Drive it still
looks better than the O WCS brick like
design now in terms of durability the
LaCie wins by far
covered with a rubber bumper all around
so it won't get scratched up like some
of the others it also includes pressure
shock dust and even ip67 water
resistance which none of the others have
and it also has three meter drop
protection the Samsung x5 actually
includes a metal protection frame on the
inside to protect the SSD so it's rated
to resist a drop from around six feet
but the plastic frame could still crack
the g-drive is actually rated with an
impressive 10 feet of drop protection
and while the in void Pro X is built out
of aluminum and comes with the rubber
bumper it doesn't have any official drop
ratings but it should still be pretty
durable now let's compare the included
Thunderbolt three cables this time both
the Samsung x5 and the G Drive came with
high quality cables that are around a
foot and a half long the LaCie SSDs
cable was actually less than half as
long which may be nice for portability
but it's restricting if you want to use
the cable for anything else and the o WC
cable is short and permanently attached
to the SSD itself which you obviously
can't lose but it could lead to a
nightmare if the cable gets damaged in
any way more on this in just a bit in
terms of the warranties the LaCie beats
the rest of these out by far what the
five-year warranty a five-year data
recovery service plan and a one-month
subscription to all of the Adobe
Creative Cloud apps the G Drive also
comes with a five-year warranty but the
OWCA and Samsung drives only come with a
three-year warranty which is still
pretty decent but it doesn't match up to
the others now let's get into
performance before running our speed
tests we reformatted all the drives 2x
fat which is the most universal large
file format that works on both Mac OS
and Windows 10 for our first test we use
black magics disk speed test to see the
maximum speed these drafts can run at
using the 5 gigabyte file option the
Samsung x5 was the fastest by about a
hundred megabytes per second which is
pretty impressive but we didn't see
speeds nearing the advertised 2800
megabytes per second in terms of the
write speeds the G Drive was actually
the fastest with write speeds of up to
two thousand two hundred and eighty
megabytes per second so between those
two benchmarks it seems like it's a draw
between the Samsung and the G Drive now
let's get into the stress test where we
transferred a 172 gigabyte file to and
from the drives in our Mac Pro which
runs fast enough to not limit the drives
we noticed that when transferring the
file to each Drive the right speed
slowed down after a certain amount of
data was transferred after around 48
gigabytes the Samsung x5 slowed down to
around 1200 megabytes per second for the
G Drive it only took 20 gigabytes of
data to slow the drive down to fourteen
hundred megabytes per second faster than
the Samsung now for the LaCie
it slowed down to a much lower 1000
megabytes per second after 30 gigabytes
of data was transferred and finally the
owz drive was actually the worst slowing
down to 950 megabytes per second after
30 gigs of data now if you don't
understand how SLC cache works let me
explain it to you on each of these
drives the storage is made up of
multiple storage chips now in most
drives there are some very fast chips
and then the rest of them are slower in
the case of the LaCie drive it has 30
gigs of fast chips that can write at a
very fast a thousand nine hundred and
thirty megabytes per second but anything
beyond that up to the rest of the 970
gigs slows down to around a thousand
megabytes per second that means if
you're transferring a file from your
computer to the drive that's over 30
gigabytes large it'll slow down to the
slower speeds after 30 gigs have been
transferred so we actually tested how
long it took to transfer our 172 gig
file to each of the drives and the G
Drive was the fastest because even
though it had the least amount of cache
the speed of the slower chips was the
fastest at 1,400 megabytes per second
the Samsung x5 was in second place
because I had the most SLC cache in the
slower chips were almost as fast as the
chips on the G Drive and out of all of
them the odbc drive was the slowest now
let's move on to a read speed
overheating test we transferred about
500 gigabytes of data from each drive to
our Mac Pro without give
them a chance to cool down to test the
cooling performance and all but one
drive performed perfectly fine not
slowing down throughout the entire 500
gigs of data that one drive actually
kept ejecting itself over and over again
so we couldn't even transfer over 200
gigs of data non-stop and that drive was
the ODA VC envoi Pro we tried
reformatting it multiple times and
nothing would help we're not sure if we
had a bad drive or not but we didn't
experience any issues with the other
drives to make it even worse the cable
is attached permanently so we couldn't
even test out a different cable to see
if that was the issue so in terms of
performance the G Drive is the winner
with the Samsung being the runner-up and
the ODBC being the worst because of the
ejection issues now we actually dug deep
into each drive to figure out which SSD
they're packing and we were able to find
the tbw stats for each drive which is
basically the amount of data you can
write on the drive before it starts to
fail into our surprise the LaCie Drive
was rated for a much higher amount of
data written compared to the other
drives blowing them away in terms of
reliability with the ODBC drive being
the worst in one last thing the LaCie
drive is actually the only drive out of
the bunch that also works with USB C
allowing you to transfer data between
your Mac and other Windows devices that
don't have Thunderbolt 3 now for our
final category price now I want to
mention that prices fluctuate all the
time so make sure to check the links
down in the description below
the Samsung x5 is currently available
for 450 dollars on bnh and actually 350
dollars on Amazon but we do expect a
price to go down on bnh to match Amazon
soon the G Drive is currently 380
dollars the lacy is 400 dollars and the
owz Drive is a much lower two hundred
and eighty dollars so with all of that
comparison testing finished let's finish
with their purchasing recommendations
now although the owz drive is the
cheapest we would not recommend it
because the bulky size and the
permanently attached cable which can get
damaged and render the drive useless now
if you're looking for the most
rugged and reliable drive without caring
too much about having the absolute best
performance we would go with the lazy
because of its excellent portability
rugged design ip67 water resistance
backwards compatibility with USBC
excellent reliability and longer 5-year
warranties and data rescue services now
if you're not planning on transferring
very large files we would actually
recommend the samsung x5 because of its
sleek design long Thunderbolt 3 cable
and massive 48 gigs of SOC cache that
will help it be the fastest drive for
transferring a lot of small files
now while the G Drive doesn't have the
best looking or compact design it gets
10 feet of drop protection a nice 5 year
warranty along cable and by far the
fastest performance out of all of these
drives at $380 is definitely not the
cheapest out of the bunch but it
excelled in a lot of the categories and
blew the competition away in terms of
performance but once again if you're all
about reliability and you want the
freedom to use your drive with not only
Thunderbolt 3 but also USB C then the
LaCie drive easily beats out the rest
and without a doubt that's definitely
the drive that we would purchase
ourselves now we're actually going to be
building our own custom DIY portable SSD
using a Thunderbolt 3 nvme SSD enclosure
in a PCI Express 4.0 m2 SSD to see if we
can beat the speeds of these drives at a
much lower price so if you're interested
in seeing that click that circle above
to subscribe and check out those two
videos right over there thanks for
watching and we'll see you guys in the
next video
[Music]